les écoliers de trappes auront école le
mercredi matin dès la rentrée 2013 une
décision officielle prise après un mois
de consultation sur les rythmes de
l'enfant pour le contenu de cette demi
journée supplémentaire rien n'est encore
défini elle pourrait se diviser en trois
temps garderie animations et éducation
les autres jours l'accueil se ferait
toujours 17h30 pour un début de
l'enseignement à 9 heures après une
pause de deux heures les cours
reprendraient de 14h à 16h30 le créneau
jusqu'à 18h30 est réservée pour le
moment à la garderie et l'aide aux
devoirs des évolutions du temps
périscolaire sont encore à déterminer
nous sommes en train de préparer avec
rendez vous avec le directeur régional
du cnfpt de façon à former nos
animateurs au dessus du but du bafin de
façon à correspondre à des activités
plus culturelles et qui assure un
prolongement de ce qui se fait dans le
projet éducatif
la commune s'engage à financer ce projet
qui concernera sur le long terme les
élèves de 2 à 18 ans mais les
inquiétudes des parents persiste sur
cette nouvelle semaine de quatre jours
et demi et voient ce qu'ils en ont
besoin comment ça va être fait
je sais pas comment ça va se passer
quelques horizons rond est ce que ce
sera des cours qui seront lourds comme
la lecture les mathématiques ou est ce
que ce sera des activités
au revoir des questionnements qui
resteront en suspens en attendant la
réunion publique prévue par la ville
mercredi 10 avril à l'auditorium de
trappe dès 19h30